hello everyone and hello everyone again
as there was one missing yesterday I
have no idea why it happened I hope now
everything is fixed with my recording
software and we can get on with the show
so this is a game from Round six Kingdom
versus young opponent she the leader of
the tournament but before we check out
this game I would just like to mention
something about the game mama D our
versus our onion that we already covered
two rounds ago in this position a lot of
you asked that after Bishop to f1 that
the Bishop to e2 is not in fact winning
because the Queen team captured a bishop
and I'm sorry I forgot to mention this
line it is a very important line so
let's just go over it now you said after
Queen captures it's not enough for for
black but it actually is after rook
captures Bishop captures white is up a
piece but you push a four and the past
points are simply too strong for example
you play Bishop c4 try and keep an eye
on on the a2 square root d8 is coming
you cannot trade if you trade then just
be 5 B 3 B 4 B 3 and it's a game over
then the a pawn will will Queen and it's
nothing you can do you will have to keep
an eye on too many squares then it will
be impossible
so after rugby 1 you avoid the trade now
rook d2 is coming threatening rook C 2
followed by rooks you won't check which
will be winning king F 1 and now you get
rook the C 2 preparing this Bishop to a2
now okay rook see one chair can be met
with King e2 as the bishop is now
guarding the rook but now you push b5
and hear why this helpless kinky one
you'll put before King b1 b3 and it's
all over
whatever you do let's say you capture
here this rook will not be able to move
for the rest of the game and now there
are a lot of winning ideas here for
black the simplest one is just bring
your King over here since the white rope
cannot move bring it over to a to win
the rook move the King Queen the pawn
and its mate so that's basically the
easiest way to do it but I just wanted
to cover that as a lot of you were
interested in what happens if Queen
captures so getting back to this game
ding versus neppo it's round 6 like I
said Nepos still in the lead foot point
the head of Magnus cross and inversely
so so let's see what happens here we do
have a nice photo of the two gentlemen
here there you have it both of them deep
in thought so let's just enjoy that for
a moment
and now let's get on with the show so
Dean has the white pieces and he opens
with c4 so the English opening with E 5
by neppo g3 preparing to fianchetto the
light square Bishop Knight to f6 and now
bush of the g2 with d5 by nepo we have C
capture Sun d5 Knight Tetris on d5 and
Knight to f3 a line being very often
placed with the white pieces and now
comes Knight to c6 if you're thinking
about pushing the e4 pawn here don't
think about stuff like that because you
know Queen a4 check will just pick up
the pawn and you've blundered your pawn
here so not something you want to do so
nice to see 6 here and we have castles
by dink and here there already is a game
being played in this line he played
against Wesley so in the no way all the
books not a championship but in the
blade section where Wesley played Knight
back to b6 but here an epic goes Bishop
to e7 it's not a new move or anything
it's just a different line with d4
biding and now you can push the e4 pawn
so with E for attacking the knight
Knight to e5 now threatening to win the
e4 pawn here and now f5 defending the
pawn so still the mainline Knight
captures and c6 b captures and now Queen
to c2 putting pressure on the c6 pawn
here and here you can choose to defend
the pawn in a in a lot of different ways
Queen to d6 is the most usual way people
defend this pawn but here Knepper goes
Knights Derby for attacks the Queen and
also the knight now nicely guards the c6
pawn bishop cards the night so all is
well here we have Quinta a4 again
keeping this pressure here now
threatening a3 to kick away the night
and well win material and now Bishop to
d7 and here and there is one game that
reached this position in 2001 in the
European in the European Rapids
championship in the playoffs
Vasili when Chuck had this position
against alexei sure he played Knights
the c3 and he was able to win this game
with the white pieces but here we have a
three by ding and it is a new move in
this position so ok as of move 12 we
have a completely new game so here Napo
has to decide does he move the knight or
does he first place c5 make some trades
in the center
he decides to move away with the night
if he goes see five okay then there's a
discovery on the Queen you move the
Queen but then again you have to move
the knight and white will capture you're
gonna play c6 and you get this position
which is perfectly fine for black but
netwo decides you know once you push up
on you you can never undo [ __ ] so he
waits for the right moment
Knight the d5 and now Knight to c3
biding continuous development and again
do you push c5 here you can although it
doesn't win anything since Queen b3
comes with an attack on the night and
after you trade here Queen captures not
the Queen nicely guards the the d4 pawn
you can capture here and after black
castles it's a it's a nice position for
both white and black but nepos still
doesn't want to make any you know
concrete decisions first Bishop to b6
now what ideas of well maybe even
castling pushing a for starting an
attack on the Kings side and ding
doesn't allow a ding says okay our King
is still in the center of the board
I'm the one that's opening lines here so
f3 threatening to capture on e4 with
each captures on f3 Bishop captures on
f3 and now Knights the B 6 pushing the
Queen back with Queen to b3 now
preventing the black king from castling
King side and now Queen to f6 going
after the d4 pawn and leaving the option
of maybe even castling queenside if
needed but if not the King can always
just just move if you know trouble
arises so what do you play here the d4
pawn is under attack and the dingoo
force defended it with Bishop to e3 who
wouldn't it's such a lovely developing
move defends the d4 pawn develops the
bishop but there is one beautiful move
here that is actually rook to f2
something no one would play but it's
just beautiful when you see why it works
you just you can give up the d4 pawn and
black cannot capture it I black captures
and then you get Bishop captures on c6
threatening the rook here and then after
Bishop captures Queen a6 check is now
both the Queen and the bishop are away
from the e6 square and now you're I mean
you're not doing great as black here
because if you go for example to d8 then
Bishop g5 just wins the game you either
have to give up material
here there should be seven or you give
up the Queen but either way you're just
you know dead lost here and if you don't
after Queenie six if you go to the F
file now you can capture an f5 not yet
as the rock is pinned but you just keep
away the Queen and after something let's
say Quincy for you want to trade Queens
rook a five will be made so a very
sneaky line on how to react the Queen to
f6 this troop to have to move our but of
course you know being played the normal
human line with Bishop to e3 with Queen
to g6 now and not allowing Bishop to a5
check but also preparing to get the rook
into the game also maybe with ideas of
of starting an attack on the King side
maybe even h5h for and it's very
unlikely that the black king will be
castling kingside so Bishop to f2 ding
now says okay our ski your king is still
in the center of the board I'm ready to
open lines I want to play efore and here
you could Castle queenside but it could
be a bit dangerous d5 would come now
opening more lines towards the black
King if c5 closing them then a4 is
coming with a five-night can come to b5
it's just going to be a very hard
position to defend for netball so here
after this Bishop to f2 we have h5 Nepos
starts an attack on the King side and
well if you look at this position who do
you think is the side that should be
attacking in this position I'll just let
you you know think about that for a
moment
so nepo says ok your king is still in
the center I'm opening up lines and Napo
ignores the network continues the attack
on the Kings side with h4 and now e
captures on f5 as the Queen is under
attack you have to react to this with
Queen captures on f5 and now rook 81
with check so you have to move the King
like we said if anything happens you can
always go King to d8 and now Knight to
e4 the bishop on d6 is a strong
attacking piece so of course a ding
wants to get rid of it with 8 and well
here never played the Queen to g6
putting more pressure on the G file but
you could also just trade everything
here a pawn captures captures and Bishop
captures pawn captures but the problem
for black is that it's not all that
clear how to continue the attack and the
white pieces are just so wonderfully
plays
the king is still in the center unless
you do something about it you're never
getting this rock into the game so it's
much harder for Napa to play this
position if Queen h7 with the threat of
checkmate rook f2 just blocks everything
the bishop here such a nice defender you
don't have a good ways of continuing
this attack so after 94 we have Queen to
g6 by Napo instead keeping everything on
the board but now it's just a better
trade for ding as he gets to trade the
night for the bishop and he is gonna be
left with the bishop pair we have Knight
captures here C captures and now d5 just
you know still wanting to open lines of
course that's what you want to do neppo
not interested he wants to close the
lines we have c5 and now comes a for
preparing to push a5 and kick away the
night and what do you do here well you
can't push a 5 or something like that as
the knight would be hanging so here
Napo just grabs the point with Bishop
captures an a4 and now dink achieved
what he wanted now he can play Queen t3
and now after before there will be no
more ways for black to prevent you know
just busting open the position so rook
to e8
nepo gets this rock into the game he's
hoping to get some King to c7 and the
other broke into the game action and now
Dean continues with his plan B for now
he's ready to capture here and then the
lines for the bishop pair will be open
here if you push c4 you don't really
gain anything then b5 is coming and then
all the lines are open and it will be
very hard very hard to do to defend this
with black so rook the c8 by Napo and
now comes B captures on c5 first never
throws in a nice addition to with rook
after Sonny 1 rook after Sonny 1h
captures and g3 H captures and g3 and D
captures on c5 and now how do you
continue this game with wood white well
you want to capture on c5 but first you
have to further defend the g3 pawn as
you cannot move the bishop so kink the
g2 you prepare Bishop captures here
never played the Queen Queen to c2 now
with a double well he has to defended
the c5 pawn twice and now you're doing
in this position what do you play here I
feel free to pause the video and
continue the attack with white while I
have a nice tip of my water for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
threatener of mate in one and for those
of you who just wanna enjoy the show
Queen to III now you're already
threatening mate in one and black has to
decide how to defend it's not all that
easy to defend there are some ways you
can go Bishop d7 King c7 rook the c7
nipple gotta decides for rook to c7 and
he tries to create well an escape route
for the King but with this Bishop nicely
on this diagonal I mean who are we
kidding d6 is coming at some point we
have Queen to e6 not allowing nip of
King to escape also now ideas like g4
followed by Bishop to h4 check or
possible which pretty much ends the game
so neppo has to make some sort of a
escape route for his King he goes rook
to d7 maybe trying to get his game to c7
but it's getting harder and harder with
d6 not allowing it also now this
diagonal for the bishop is open and here
with King to c8 and here again feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
crushing ball for white here there are a
lot of winning moves but one is a force
checkmate in six so feel free to do it
while pausing the video for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you have just beaten Yanni promisee the
leader of the creation Grantchester in
zagreb and for those who just wanna
enjoy the show
rook to h1 with the font covering c7 the
bishop covering this entire diagonal
there is no stopping rook to h8 the only
sword of Defense is King b8 making room
for the night here but then you just
play rocket a check you walk with the
knight Knight to c8 and now after Queen
to d5 there is no more defending mate on
a 8 so nepo of course did not want to
try anything here even though never got
out of some really crazy positions not
only in this tournament but in
every tournament as it's just hit the
way the way he plays the game here he
decided not to not to do anything after
this rook to h1 move as of course
everything loses so yeah an excellent
victory for dink and a nice way for him
to get back into the tournament but as
for young upon mushy it means that he's
no longer the sole leader of the
tournament we're now gonna check out
well first let's check out this very
nice photo here you have it and
therefore being a true gentleman of the
game offering a handshake to dink
resigning the game with a smile on his
face no that's that's that's how real
chess is played you always have to be a
gentleman and here you can see that in a
poll and there is one such dude so there
you have it and also we're now going to
show the standing set aside and not show
them in the previous video maybe not to
spoil it as no one actually knew that
Nepal lost the game so here they are now
it's a bit of a different Magnus and
Wesley caught up to Nepal now it's
Carlsen neppo and Wesley with four
points three people with three and a
half Fabiana karana Dingley Rand now
after this win with over Nepal and Levin
Aragon with three and a half done with
two and a half we have maxime beaugeois
graphic and Sergey Karjakin and then we
have with two point onigiri soccer mom
in Europe and Hikaru Nakamura after
losing the game to Magnus in the video
you've seen well yesterday so we're
never go wrong in this game no we're
really it was just a series of
suboptimal moves move after move and
then Indian thing just got opposition
that was overwhelming but I think that
the quote above the board is more than
sufficient for this game that is
dangerous to maintain equality at the
cost of placing the pieces passively
something I learned you know I playing
stronger players you know you think you
will have a drawer or something if you
just have equal material on the board
even having your pieces placed passively
but it's never the case you will always
lose that game so you know it's better
to give up some material to gain
activity then then to suffer passively
and here never really struggled to get
his well pieces into the game and didn't
just capitalized Indian sure that
the game kingdom versus yonder Pony she
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Jeff graves and David Montfort for
his son Tom it's his sons Tom's birthday
so he said that he made a contribution
in honor of his son's birthday so I wish
you a very happy birthday Tom hope you
have a great celebration and hope you
win many many chess games in the in the
days to come
so like I said as usual you can check to
my previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this lovely
tournament checking up on your
suggestions and doing what we usually do
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day